désavoué par sa majorité le maire de
coignières jean-pierre sevestre n'a pas
pu faire voter les délibérations
concernant les comptes de gestion et
administratif 2010 est que conseil
municipal reporter le 19 juin dernier
faute d'accueil suffisant c'est une
nouvelle fois déroulé dans un climat
agité et divisé c'est la première fois
que j'entends une telle situation donc
je vais voir comment on va aussi mais
attire jeu
et soumettre donc le compte
administratif qui ont approuvé à la
sous-préfecture et puis voir
effectivement l'évolution des évolutions
des choses au cours des prochaines
semaines
depuis plusieurs mois à rien ne va plus
entre le maire et son conseil
entre le projet de communes nouvelles
avec maurepas et des soupçons
d'irrégularités au sein de son équipe
jean-pierre sevestre a été pris à partie
le mot démission a été prononcée à
plusieurs reprises à commencer par
l'ancien maire de la ville si le 1er
septembre il n'a pas démissionné
sa vie va devenir infernal
certains oueds pétition disait qu'il
fallait criqui de la ville que je vais
plus à quoi vous demandons la démission
de l'ensemble de son équipe
demandez ce qui reste autour de lui
aujourd'hui qui institue à peu près un
tiers de conseil municipal ça suffirait
effectivement à provoquer de nouvelles
élections
le conseil municipal s'est terminée par
une mise en demeure à l'encontre de
jean-pierre sevestre plus d'un tiers des
membres demandent au maire de convoquer
un nouveau conseil avec 12 points
obligatoires
parmi eux l'élection d'un conseiller
communautaire à saint quentin en
yvelines ou encore le maintien du
deuxième adjoint ali bout slam dans ses
fonctions